the date is set for an historic summit
between North and South Korean leaders
it will be just the third since the
Korean War North Korea's Kim jong-un
will meet South Korea's moon jae-in on
April 27th it'll happen at peace house
on the South Korean side of the
Demilitarized Zone this week kim at
chinese president xi jinping for the
first time in Beijing Ben Tracy is there
Ben good morning a good morning the main
event for Kim Jong moon of course would
be a summit with President Trump and mr.
Trump has said he would like to meet the
North Korean leader by the end of May we
sat down with US ambassador to China
terry branstad to talk about the high
stakes diplomacy I think we've got to be
very careful in dealing with him he's
feeling the heat of the UN sanctions and
the pressure that's being placed on him
and maybe it means he's kind of changing
his attitude a little bit it's been four
months since kim jong-un has tested a
missile instead he's launched a
diplomatic offensive successfully
getting both the president of South
Korea and the United States to agree to
meet with him why does president Trump
want to sit down with him what is the
goal well I think the goal is indeed to
try to get a verifiable denuclearization
program this has got to be something
that is real and verifiable and and
something that they won't renege on as
they did in the past during Kim jong-un
surprise visit to Beijing this week he
received a very warm welcome from
Chinese President Xi Jingping a displays
seen by many as the two countries
showing they're still close allies ahead
of Kim jong-un spring summits the US has
been trying to isolate North Korea did
the way the Chinese welcomed Kim Jong
hoon here helped legitimize him the
chemistry between Kim jong-un
and the rest of the world has been
terrible the Chinese are just as fearful
of these provocations as we are but was
having Kim jong-un here in Beijing
shaking his hand
toasting was that helpful well remember
the Chinese are very good hosts so I
and read too much into that despite
rising trade tensions between the US and
China the Ambassador told me he thinks
China will continue to enforce the
international sanctions against North
Korea because China does not want the
north to have nuclear weapons hi Gail
thank you Ben Tracy reporting from
Beijing